hey guys Ryan right here we have reached
10,000 subscribers though real rejects
has reached 10,000 subscribers a lot of
youtubers you thank you videos when
you're like at in the three digits know
10,000 to me is a [ __ ] awesome number
like last year we entered our year with
like 1700 subscribers but this year were
already at 10,000 and it's like really
thanks to you guys this is not like some
hey days you should do a thank you video
thing is like no I genuinely just want
to say thank you because I see that you
a lot of you guys constantly share our
videos a lot of you guys keep commenting
and stuff and like you guys are like
[ __ ] awesome you know I we don't
really get too many haters which I'm
sure I just jinx the [ __ ] out of that
[ __ ] just now but we don't really get
too many haters even if we do you guys
will like be like [ __ ] off dude so the
fact that you guys like really go out
there and really show your love and
support that really does mean a lot best
way to stay interacted with us they said
youtubers should talk about this so that
way they can be more interactive with
her fan base huh marketing with that in
mind why don't you follow us on Twitter
and follow us on facebook sally has her
own Twitter and all the girls have their
own Twitter account jerry has his own
Twitter account about reasons to Jerry I
have my on Twitter but then there's the
real rejects Twitter we also have a
Facebook and we have an Instagram so
yeah follow us on that that would be
really sweet yeah like I really like 10
subscribers I want to say like a thank
you video man when we first started
doing this and then we would get like
one subscriber Jerry and I would freak
out like with this might actually work
like we loved talking about movies we
just really love movies like we keep our
videos under 15 minutes but if you
actually hung out with us we would talk
for long periods of time we're
considering doing podcast we'll talk
longer about the movie then the actual
length of the movie was a podcast I'm
really proud of is called haters why we
love the dark knight rises just Jerry
and I and it's on the channel now you
gotta search for it's one of those
hidden videos but it's like an hour and
a half podcast and most people who
listen to it really dig it I really love
that podcast and that's why I mean like
we can talk forever about a movie so the
fact that like you guys like to join in
and just listen to us talk about movies
and we could talk back with you as well
like that is so much fun it's like you
know like there's so much more any guys
are all across the world you know like
I'm seeing people from like Germany
Austria Japan
Hong Kong Indonesia America the greatest
country of them all [ __ ] off the rest
this is messing her I don't really know
too much about politics and all that
[ __ ] so yeah I love America I do but I
would like to visit all these other
countries and decide which one is the
best they ever knew the channel and you
subscribe thank you so much like that is
just awesome cuz it's different when you
meet my queen if you just think about
like some people just look at it as a
number i look at it as 10,000 people
individuals it's like if i meet one of
you in person it's like you're a fan of
us like that's is trippy to me they get
about a bunch of people is just crazy
man how fun it would it be if I like
just came on the crowd I don't know why
I had that imagery I've imagined seeing
a crowd of 10,000 people is just jerk
off and no it's a real pleasure doing
this and you guys keep it really fun and
like like really it is like all about
you guys you guys are that you guys
literally suck all your dicks and heat
all your [ __ ] no one could be here
tonight but everyone on the channel is
pretty stoked when they found out about
it so what they all did was they'll send
me footage and I'm gonna play it here
for you Marie is a sick right now Marie
is sick right now she's my next-door
neighbor and she won't [ __ ] film like
a ten-second thank you what a b.i.t.c.h
but I love you Marie and I kind of hate
you right now so here's the footage hey
guys Lauren here sending you my love
from San Diego I'm here for the weekend
I supposed to say thank you so much for
helping us reach 10,000 followers your
support means so much to me and thank
you so much for welcoming me on to the
channel we really wouldn't be anywhere I
thought with four of our fans so thanks
again bye hey guys it's Veronica here to
tell you how pleased I am to know that
we've reached 10,000 subscribers the
real rejects are so proud and happy to
have you guys spans and I've got to give
all the credit to ryan right though
because he is so dedicated to you guys
and so hard working and it's such a
great friend I'm honored to be a part of
this channel and I hope you keep
watching and tell your friends so we can
reach 20,000 [ __ ] peace out everyone
is Capitol Hill redundancy
I just wanna say thank you so much for
helping us reach 10,000 subscribers you
love you holy moly guys 10,000 stubs
seriously wow you know thank you so much
for making this channel what it is the
real rejects really would not be what it
is today without its viewers and some
and subs so thank you thank you so much
from all of us we really really love you
guys ten thousand yeah hey everybody oh
my goodness I thought we wouldn't reach
10,000 to like the end of the summer and
we reached it now you guys are insane I
love you so much my dog is happy to see
you thank you guys so much for all of
your support and for being there every
step of the way and all of our new
subscribers thank you for giving us a
chance because all we love in movies
that's what we do that's our life those
what we love and so I'm glad that we get
to share that with you and I'm glad you
guys enjoy that hopefully if we keep
growing will be able to do VidCon and
meet some of you guys which I think
would be amazing so keep subscribing
keep sharing our videos keep tweeting
them out keep sharing it with your
friends I love you all so much thank you
bye what's up guys it is Jerry I am on
the road again but I just wanted to stop
in really briefly and just you know they
thank you to all you guys for uh you
know supporting our little channel and
you know watching the videos and
subscribe and leave in comments and all
that you know really get an interactive
and being so kind with all your feedback
on it's a little surreal you know it's a
little weird that anybody you know
watches us and you know to think that
somebody on a computer you've never met
before
cares about anything you have a sec it's
a little bit of a head trip so I thank
you guys so much and looking forward to
bringing you all more awesome stuff
alright until next time cheers much love
sure that was nice but I took away from
that was cat was in a bikini clearly and
she didn't pan the camera down what the
[ __ ] at what the [ __ ] okay you guys
you're gonna hate me for this but you
know she does have a Facebook page but
if you happen to come across her real
facebook you see some sexy photos of her
she's also a model and damn gosh ah cat
ah yeah man no one's done that before
okay now I know I normally go off the
shoutout list but for a special video I
wanted to do a special type of shoutout
I found this thing on the YouTube
community section where you can sort by
who watches your videos the most and
they put it in order from first to the
last page like this person watches our
channel the least but you can see your
top 10 and I was like this is [ __ ]
awesome I can see the top 10 people who
watch our chat now there's other names
after 10 or I'm like I see their comment
slide you see their comments a lot
because then you know there's 10,000 you
guys now so when i look at the top 10
I'm like you know what I'm gonna shout
at a top ten to you guys let's go from
ten to one number tech Kevin market dude
I see your comments a lot you're
constantly asking for shoutouts you've
already given you a shadow constantly
asked you for shoutouts and because
you're on this list you're obviously
gonna get one but yeah you make a lot of
threats to me I think you watch this
channel just to threaten me Michael
shilly-shally tell me how to pronounce a
dude from this photo he's a black dude
yes I got a black friend you always need
a gay friend and a black friend that's
simple and then you look like you're not
racist and you're not homophobic so you
get the point across Michael I'm using
you for that my friend and kidding i
already have black friends sort of a lot
of them don't like me Anthony Smith
Anthony is my brother's name so i kind
of like you but i also sort of hate you
at the same time anthony smith you you
do common an awful lot and so thank you
for constantly comedy and constantly
watching our videos you are number eight
on the list so Thank You number eight
you've been great Neal Murray this
student remember said we have the best
reaction channel on the planet
so yeah thank you neil murray you're the
coolest dude out there in number seven
wise there's an order of coolest Elise
coolest in it there's a top ten and your
number seven on that a boost your way up
to number one star watching all my
videos you can do it you can do it how
bad do you want to be number one taylor
houston number six taylor Houston taylor
dude you should start I tell some in
every comment you should start reviewing
movies dude every time he doesn't leave
like a comment he leaves like a movie
review for anything or a trailer review
it is awesome I read all of them it's
you know hard to give feedback when I'm
like both yeah already said my review so
so yeah you start up your own channel
now because i read your [ __ ] really
start up like a blog or something you're
great you know putting into words how
you feel about a movie so dude do that
[ __ ] Taylor okay there's also a girl's
name I wanna sing a really hot chick
named taylor and odd times i would
masturbate to her for some of the best
sex I've ever had Tyrone Hamilton you've
got a cool thumbnail it's a double oh
seven that's higher own man like I said
earlier I think your black would be cool
to be my second black friend what number
are you n 9 8 7 6 5 you are number 5
you're right in the middle thanks a lot
man really appreciate the support you
even gave me the channel you do comment
a lot and so please continue to love us
I don't want to lose your Kevin harp
wait a minute it's either Kevin Harper
Kevin market that threatens me a lot if
you are that person again you better
watch out coming for you you son of a
[ __ ] you murdered my wife and kids
you're gonna get what's coming here see
you on the battlefield Titan cult 2008
number three uh dude 2008 was a good
year I was 18 that year that's when I
lost my virginity yeah it was awesome
except that at Cana mon but you know
when you fall in love you brew look we
don't need condoms anymore we're in love
we're gonna get married and we're gonna
be together forever lies 2008 was a
horrible Vanessa will will go by Vanessa
will will F gusto mo um this is like I
think she's like a 15 year old girl
actually which sounds so weird say nine
over um yeah she looks at another
country and I don't you know like send
her photos of myself or ask her to send
me look it's not how it sounded is what
I'm trying to say she watches our videos
a [ __ ] ton she's really cool sorry it's
I can't reply back to your account and
some people are behaving
skype but i always get the skype
messages like 10 hours later because the
notifications are not going off on my
phone for some reason but Vanessa thank
you i wish i could talk back with you
but you know just be careful not to be
attracted to guys who don't talk as a
lot of girls are attracted guys don't
give them attention and treat them like
[ __ ] but when they come across a nice
guy like me they don't know how to
appreciate people like us and you do not
want to become one of those girls when
you're older you want to respect
yourself and like guys that like you
back good fan are not doing that and
it's your life not mine I don't give a
[ __ ] but you guys ready for number one
number one everyone's gonna remember
your name [ __ ] Yousef a straw
the stew made a tribute video for us I
was like thirteen and a half minutes
long this dude [ __ ] cool man I
remember the first time he actually
talked with us he was saying like he was
going through a tough period and I don't
know if you still are hopefully you're
not if you are marijuana is a best
solution i could tell you man it fixes
all your problems any drug really does
so you set a shroff this dude is really
[ __ ] cool he he said is going through
a tough period our videos really help
them feel better like when someone says
that that is really [ __ ] me and I
know someone else said that recently but
I left my list at work of my subscriber
shows I need to obtain that work and
then I'll remember who you are and don't
worry come around e I think you were
like the first person ever tell me that
and that really made an impact on me and
I'll never forget that dude so thank you
so much for you know watching our videos
to most you you're awesome dude and all
you guys are awesome like I said all of
you guys just cuz I didn't see your name
cuz mean you're not awesome so thank you
guys so much we reach 10,000 hopefully
we can get another 10,000 imagine a
hundred thousand we got ways to go
people we got a real in people share our
videos and [ __ ] I love people who tell
me how to run a YouTube channel who
don't run a YouTube channel they all I'm
like yeah okay I know I know so ya know
you guys make it really rewarding I
always look forward to the comments I'm
a little behind on comments cuz there's
a lot more lately yeah if I haven't come
to bat to you in the past week it's
still catching up it's kind of hard to
keep track so yeah you have a good night
people thank you